the heat is especially shocking in the
uk a country not prepared for this kind
of weather people are looking for relief
wherever they can find it roxanna
seberry is in london roxanna good
morning what are people doing there
vlad here in trafalgar square some
people are pulling themselves off in the
fountain behind me the uk has just
broken its record high temperature today
of 102 degrees fahrenheit this heat wave
has come here from continental europe
where wildfires continue to rage
from the air
and from the ground firefighters in
spain are scrambling to put out dozens
of wildfires
desperate residents are also stepping in
i feel so impotent this man says because
there's no solution
this farmer tried to dig a trench to
stop the blaze from approaching but he
fled his clothes on fire his body badly
burned nearby flames forced these
passengers to a terrifying halt before
they moved on to safety
in france hot winds are hampering
efforts to contain wildfires that have
scorched tens of thousands of acres
meteorologists warn parts of the country
now face what they're calling a heat
apocalypse as the u.k also swelters a
london airport suspended flights
yesterday after part of the tarmac
melted and a police officer took pity on
a guard still in full uniform at
buckingham palace
in a country where not even an estimated
5 percent of homes have air conditioning
many residents and visitors are finding
practical ways to stay cool there's air
conditioning in the hotel
so yeah we rang ahead to make sure
but global warming will only get worse
the future king is warning if we don't
act now as i've tried to indicate for
quite some time
the climate crisis really is a genuine
emergency and tackling it is utterly
essential
as the unsecretary general put it we
have a choice collective action or
collective suicide fortunately there is
some relief on the way to london
tomorrow a bit of rain and cooler
temperatures tony
roxanna sabri for us in a sweltering
london roxanna thank you very much